只今の時刻
午前四時です
おはようございます
朝六時半には家でなきゃ
というわけで、今日あと二時間しか寝れません
はじめしゃちょーです
寝れないときどうする
まあ普通に目覚ましかければいいんですけど
目覚ましかけてもいいんですけども
やっぱさ、ちょっと不安があるじゃないですか
目覚ましだと
ひょっとしたら途中で電池が抜けて
駄目かもしれないし
設定し忘れて、ならないかもしれない
電池が切れそうで音が小さいかもしれない
いろんな原因があって
目覚ましがならない事があるかもしれないんですけど
まぁ一応かけとくよ？
もっとさ、こうさ
ねえ
何か、もっと
起きたいじゃんパッと
何か、調べたんですけども
これがすごい強いという噂を聞きました
これです
こちらです　ちょっと開けていきましょう
なに？あれテレビでやってたんすよ
見てないんですけども
なに？こう電機がすごくて飛び起きちゃうみたいな
おお！
ええちょっと待って
これは多分すぐ充電するタイプなので
充電しときまっしょう
先手必勝だ
ああ！
点滅した！
ほんとに強いかどうかはこの俺が自分で確かめる！
この中の部分に今充電しているこれをいれて完成らしいです
ひとまずアプリが必要らｓｓｓｓ
もうやばそうだな～
もう見た目からしてやばそうなんですけど
なんかこれを押したら揺れるらしいです
やだやだやだ
つけるともう痛いってこと？
これ逃げれねえ！
ええ、ええええ～～
押しますよ
いきます
じゃあnext
次押すと音が鳴るらしい
おお～すごい
いきますよ
いてええええええ！！！！！
やばいやばいやばい
いまめっちゃ痛かったんですけど
ええちょっとじゃあ次は
50%でやってみましょう
じゃあ50%です
あ！いてええええええ！！！！！
じゃあ70%もう俺死ぬんじゃない？
70%！
はああああ！！
80%！
ほんとに！！まじで痛い！！
いた！うわわわわわわわーーー！？！？
ちょっと一回剝がしていい？
命の危険を感じる
もう目がバッチリ覚めたんだけど
もう100%にしとこう
100%の電力MAXにして
では、わい今からもう寝るので
まだ僕は100%の電力を味わってないので
1時間半しか寝れないんですけど
僕が！6時に完璧に起きれるように期待してますからね
お前の!100%見せてくれや！
なに俺数々の電撃受けてきたよ
こんな電気なんてもう朝飯前なんすよ！
起きない覚悟でいきます！
もう明日大事なことがあるけど起きない
グッドラック！
ううううううぇあああああああ